when I was a kid we used to live in two
archiver
during part of the summer months when we
was working out there live in little
shacks almost like Okies just sort of
that and the AMC was great Jen's really
old-fashioned too
Delsin is picking an edible seaweed off
the beach at low tide
my great great uncle's back in the early
nineteen hundred's the adulteress and
then my grandfathers did too and then
the father and me down through the
generations with your dark I was a pawn
I don't know it must be over half a mile
long I guess and it's enclosed by a
natural seawall there's high cliffs
surrounded most of it except the western
side I guess that's why they always
called the dark Harbor because it takes
a while for the Sun to hit down there in
the morning then some ventures try it
out there that didn't pan out they
blamed it on that pirate's curse fire
and his crew come ashore and they buried
their treasure up on top of the hill the
captain got them all drunk and then he
murdered them all so we have the
treasure himself but in the process he
got caught too and he bled to death so
anyone that's tried to find his treasure
has all met an untimely death since then
and so there's been a curse on on the
whole place since then
get into it with my dad when I was a
small child started and going dolphin
with him then as I got old enough I went
on my own and still doing it for the
last 46 years
then that is a long time it's some of
the older guys there who can't go and
they tell me that all go while you can
cuz you'll miss it
these guys are 280 years old you know
and they miss it they wish they could go
I don't know I think I can find
something else to do
nothing has changed much it's still
picked by hand and still dried by the
Sun outside
they're all homemade shakin machines
just an old washing machine motor prongs
inside that turn and trash your belts
around to convoke the bottom I guess
that's pretty much what it does
I just kind of like working alone in the
peace and quiet with my own thing
without a bunch of people around this
way I prefer it the only ones that go
along that I know of is me and my friend
Donny Richie I think were the only two
that go along the only Richie grunts the
idea of putting the bicycle wheel on the
other end
I love dumps most grandma Tanner's do to
love it I know guys who have to keep
some on hand during the winter months
when you can't really buy any fresh
towels they keep them there deep freeze
and hopefully it lost them until the
next season starts up again you can't
feed a gram an aunt or bad belts they
won't accept it it's got to be good
fresh dollar you won't have anything to
do with it
you